voit que c'est les mêmes recettes ya
aucune rupture avec le passé au
contraire au contraire on évoque même le
semestre européen je vous rappelle quand
même que ce semestre européen est
utilisée actuellement pour détruire
certains acquis sociaux comme par
exemple le système des retraites où nous
dit il faut travailler plus longtemps la
commission européenne dans son nouveau
papier propose de porter l'âge de la
retraite à 70 70 où 72 ans notamment en
lituanie tandis que les gens et les
hommes en lituanie vive jusqu'à je pense
l'espérance de vie moyenne de 71 1 ou de
71,5 en ce qui veut dire que
pratiquement on est en train de détruire
des acquis sociaux aujourd'hui
concrètement et face à cela nous avons
un sommet qui est non certains principes
qu'on peut partager ou pas mais qui
ancre surtout le semestre européen est
donc cet instrument d'austérité dans les
consciences et dans les textes européens
[Musique]